since you mentioned open pile I'd love
to get an update
in the company number one come AI world
how are things going there in the
development
of uh semi-autan was driving
you know
almost no one talks about FSD anymore
and even less people talk about open
pilot
we've solved the problem like we solved
it years ago
what's the problem exactly
well what what does solving it mean
solving means how do you build a model
that outputs a human policy for driving
how do you build a model that given uh
you know reasonable set of sensors
outputs a human policy for driving
uh so you have you know companies like
women Cruise which are hand coding these
things that are like quasi-human
policies
then you have
Tesla and maybe even to more of an
extent comma asking okay how do we just
learn human policy of data
the big thing that we're doing now and
we just put it out on Twitter
at the beginning of comma
we published a paper called learning a
driving simulator and the way this thing
worked was it's a it was an auto encoder
and then an RNN in the middle right uh
you take an auto encoder you compress
the picture you use an RNN predict the
next date and these things were you know
it was a laughingly bad simulator right
this is 2015 error machine learning
technology
today we have vqvae and Transformers
we're building Drive GPT basically
Drive GPT okay uh so and that's trained
on what is it trained in a
self-supervised way it's trained on all
the driving data to predict the next
frame so really trying to uh learn a
human policy what would a human do well
actually our simulator is conditioned on
the pose so it's actually a simulator
you can put in like a state action pair
and get out the next date
okay
um and then once you have a simulator
you can do RL in the simulator and RL
will get us that human policy
so it transfers yay
RL with a reward function not asking is
this close to the human policy but
asking would a human disengage if you
did this Behavior
okay let me think about the distinction
there what a human disengage
or a human disengage
that um
correlates I guess with human policy but
it could be different so it's it uh it
doesn't just say what would a human do
it says what would a good human driver
do and uh such that the experience is
comfortable
but also not annoying in that like the
thing is very cautious
so it's not finding a nice balance
that's that's interesting it's a nice
it's asking exactly the right question
what will make our customers happy
right A system that you never want to
disengage because usually this
engagement is just almost always a sign
of I'm not happy with what the system is
doing usually um there's some that are
just I felt like driving and those are
always fine too but they're just going
to look like noise in the data
but even though I felt like driving
maybe yeah that's even that's a signal
like why do you feel like driving
here you need to
re-calibrate your relationship with the
car okay so what that that's really
interesting
um how close are we to solving
self-driving
um
it's hard to say
we haven't completely closed the loop
yet so we don't have anything built that
truly looks like that architecture yet
we have prototypes and there's bugs
um so we are a couple bug fixes away
might take a year might take 10. what's
the nature of the bugs are these uh
these major philosophical bugs logical
bugs what kind of what kind of bugs are
we talking about oh they're just like
they're just like stupid bugs and like
also we might just need more scale
um we just massively expanded our
compute cluster a comma uh we now have
about two people worth of compute 40
beta flops
well people
are different
I have 20 fade flops that's a person I
mean it's just it's just a unit right
horses are different too but we still
call it a horsepower yeah but there's
something different about Mobility than
there is about
uh perception and action in a very
complicated world but yes well yeah of
course not all flops are created equal
if you have randomly initialized weights
it's not gonna
not all flops are created equal so we're
doing way more useful things than others
yeah yep
tell me about it okay so more data scale
means more scaling computer or scale and
scale of data both
diversity of data diversity is very
important in data uh yeah I mean we have
so we have about I think we have like 5
000 daily actives
how would you evaluate how uh FSD is
doing pretty much driving pretty well
how's that race going between calm Ai
and FSD Tesla has always wanted two
years ahead of us they've always been
one to two years ahead of us and they
probably always will be because they're
not doing anything wrong
what have you seen that's since the last
time we talked that are interesting
architectural decisions training
decisions like the way the way they
deploy stuff the architectures they're
using in terms of the software how the
teams are run all that kind of stuff
data collection anything interesting I
mean I know they're moving toward more
of an end-to-end approach
so
creeping towards end to end as much as
possible across the whole thing the the
training the data collection everything
they also have a very fancy simulator
they're probably saying all the same
things we are they're probably saying we
just need to optimize you know what is
the reward we get Negative reward for
disengagement right like everyone kind
of knows this it's just a question who
can actually build and deploy the system
yeah I mean this could it requires good
software engineering I think yeah and
the right kind of hardware
yeah the harder to run it
you still don't believe in cloud in that
regard
I have a
compute cluster in my uh us 800 amps
tiny grad it's 40 kilowatts at idle our
data center Dyson crazy with 40
kilowatts is burning just when the
computers are idle just went up sorry
sorry compute cluster
compute cluster I got it it's not a data
center yeah yeah now data centers are
clouds we don't have clouds data centers
have air conditioners we have fans that
makes it a compute cluster
I'm guessing this is a kind of uh a
legal distinction sure yeah we have a
compute cluster